When it comes to paid marketing, you're
going to want to give it some extra
thought, and consider a few
things before going out there and
paying to acquire new customers.
After all, we are a start-up so
we want to spend our money wisely.
Now, if you want to make sure
your growth is sustainable and
your money is well spent,
you want to keep in mind a few metrics.
Starting with ARPU or your average
revenue per customer, the LTV or
lifetime value per customer, and
the CPA cost per acquisition.
Now, you want to think about how much
money you're willing to spend per
customer to get them in the door.
So these are the things you need
to consider to determine this.
So there's your ARPU,
your average revenue per user.
So how much money are you going to
make per given customer over a certain
time frame?
Knowing your ARPU and your retention
rate, so how long you're keeping your
customers with you can help you
calculate your lifetime value or LTV.
Your LTV is the amount of money
you're likely to make from
a given customer over the time that
they're affiliated with your company.
Okay, let's take the lifetime
value of a gym member for example.
So let's say the member spends $20
a month over three years on their
membership.
So that's $20 a month for
12 months for three years,
giving you a total
lifetime value of $720 for
that one customer in total revenue,
about $240 per year.
Now, for startups who haven't
acquired any customers yet,
determining your LTV is
nearly impossible to do.
But since it's so helpful in
helping you define your goals and
setting a baseline, It's really worth an
effort to at least estimate it based on
the number of transactions a given
customer will make over a month or
even over a year.
Okay, let's take a aBARKment for
example.
We charge $20 a month as a fee for
sitters to be listed on our site.
And every time they get a sitting job,
we get 15% of what they're charging,
which averages out to be
around $15 per month.
And most sitters stay with us for
about 24 months, so
this makes their lifetime value $840.
Your LTV and average revenue per
user is going to help drive how
much you're willing to
spend to get new customers.
So, if our cost per acquisition is
too close to our lifetime value or
average revenue per user,
then we're doing something wrong.
However, if our cost per
acquisition is $70 per sitter,
we're profiting about $770 per
sitter we have on our site.
This should make our average revenue
per user higher than how much it costs
us to gain that user,
which is really what your goal is.
One thing I want to point out is you
should be looking at your LTV or
ARPU per segment.
Think back to market
segmentation about this.
That way you can determine how much you
could have paid to acquire different
users from different segments.
For example, if we decide to have our
dog owners pay a $50 monthly fee,
and then we get 15% of
all of their bookings,
which average out to about $22.50
a month and they stay with us for
three years,
we're looking at an LTV of $2,610.
So we know we can spend more to
gain dog owners, because their
lifetime value is significantly higher
than the lifetime value of dog sitters.
Now, if your company has
different subscriptions,
you may see that people in one
subscription group have a much lower
lifetime value than somebody
from another subscription group.
That'll help you determine how much you
want to spend on getting people into
different subscription tiers.
For example, if people in the lowest
paying subscription don't stay with
you as long,
you're not going to want to spend as
much to acquire them as a customer.
However, if people in, say your
platinum level stay with you for
a long time and
spend a ton of money with you,
you can be willing to spend a little
bit more to acquire that customer.
Now having said that,
our company is a marketplace.
So in order to maintain this healthy
marketplace We have to ensure both
supply and demand.
So sometimes we may need to spend more
on sitters to sustain our supply or
else the company would fail.
Being a company the offers to
babysit your dog without people
to actually babysit the dog,
it wouldn't work out too well.
So these metrics are valid across online
customer acquisition channels and
they're just beginning.
You can also consider conversions.
So, how many people actually become
customers, bounce rates for emails and
even traffic from specific channels and
much more.
We'll talk more about a few of these
during this lesson and the next.
So let's hear from Talley about
her advice on paid marketing.
And then, we'll start talking
about our first channel, SEM, or
search engine marketing.